how do you like being undecided do you
like being interviewed
a Peter Ustinov to great actor once I
assume that
if you like the he said I love being
interviewed because it makes me think
about things I don't think about
knows I don't drive around all day
interviewing myself
so before since you think so when it
when you're asked good questions as you
been asking good questions it forces me
to think
I like to think when this stupid
questions no
them that virtual I've had some does
yeah
%uh the by the best answers so that was
a I was a
touring a book I wrote written 16 books
Austral book and I was on a show called
good morning Dallas I could
tell you right away you can I could see
right away you know what the host and
hostess leave I
are I have something in my mind generic
gotta sit perfectly coiffed hair
and the woman have blonde hair popped
around trip and the woman was scheduled
to interview me
and she's asking a quick I can see
she's really love to questions on a
piece of paper is not listening to my
answers
and while I'm answering up she's like
fishing are here
and the crew was the mom answering the
questions of
fourth question was a what makes a good
talk show host
anti-civil I don't love about other
people
I get so should not listen but what
helps me the most
is being in the CIA because
well-being in the CIA what happens is
paid
they get me great guess and I can't tip
of spies
around the world and then she could goes
on to a pinwheel
raising children is the I
that yeah and you know that she heard a
word you're saying you know
yeah I well you don't have the right on
the side of the table 2
because I have a look at my notes want
to I'm doing pretty good about this so
my final question to you
is a I can I can tell people you're
eighty years old right that
that public had a big that published
Razorbacks party was about the other
side the Dodger Stadium with that as
bigger thrill
for your baseball guy with a role in the
shop yeah at the same time was to my
wife pulled over on how she pulled off
this at all those people up
yeah to walk into that stadium I thought
I was going to a meeting a season ticket
holders
was a logical they had a great ploy yeah
had a letter from the Dodgers to me
season ticket holder come on Friday
night was my birthday
but there was coming four days later in
I thought she was going to do something
on my birthday night
I was on Jimmy Kimmel on my actual
birthday now was booked a long time ago
so I
port they would take me somewhere after
jimmy Kimmel
right that's right por eso total
throughway
yeah and they had like almost three
hundred people at home plate
people kids in uniform playing baseball
stadiums all that up
wiping up on the scoreboard Corbally I
could I just
I just I could believe to be I can see
it in your eyes I mean baseball really
or I grew up with it is said presuming
my boys play it
the biggest thrill I get in my life is
what you my kids
yeah play I was not a good athlete
baseball family West Saturday
my son pitch for Notre Dame freshman
season
while freshman high school and
I watched him on the mound and he's you
know like as one guy sat next to me
since we
back it's a ballplayer just wait boo
seized at
swagger and me more baseball there's a
move an athlete has you could know if a
guy's a player
he's a player is the way gives out the
dugout we have this is globally look
sleepy
was any pets shutout innings and struck
out the side in the first inning
I'm saddened I'm jewish terms
fell your clearly is when you get a
thrill for something else happens
someone you care about
and I was remembering the
his birth cut per cord
on and cut that opened lead into the
fourth get yourself a No
now public i cud and I E so unborn
unknowns fifteen-years-old pigeon
nope be I'm out beautiful high school
field you notice or feel like to sleep
was just how could you top that so
nothing I bet did me eighty years
nothing top life think you answered my
final question here but how I wanted to
end this was
what do you think about my grandma would
always say what's it all about healthy
so what do you think eighty years you
interviewed live literally everybody
from every walk of life
you've talked to everybody listen to
everybody now
a father the whole thing what do you
think it's all about at the end of the
day
what do you think you know what there
was a famous
a Nobel Prize winner who lived in ninety
five years ago
and he was a a dinner table and someone
said
I forget shouldn't forget his name when
the 80 S that victim
what do you no 9b five
use William he said
and I would put this is my effort to the
only thing I know said Oh
well and that was all about Alfie
I don't know I S the Stephen Hawking
this was the smartest person in the
world of physicists in
you're the smartest person world what
don't you know
want to something you don't know and he
said women
ap I think he's married there is any yes
he is
i think is married for that the because
you're married you know
I exactly